Kim jong-il welcome to UCLA Royce hall
to the 9th annual Los Angeles Times
Festival of Books and to what amounts to
a renewed debate a kind of post scriptum
to a debate and a discussion that was
mounted a year ago at The Wiltern
Theatre on what was the eve of a war in
which we are now in meshed at that time
we had the same gentleman discussing
grave issues that faced the Republic a
year has gone by a war was begun a
dictator was toppled and we are still in
Iraq there seems to be no end in sight
public opinion is divided much has
happened we thought we would reassemble
and discuss this morning a number of
issues that seemed still to weigh
heavily and to be enormous ly pertinent
I'm going to introduce our panelists
Christopher Shearer Christopher Scheer
actually actually Christopher
Christopher Scheer there is a
Christopher Shearer and he is the son of
Robert Scheer and together they have
co-authored a book
called the five biggest lies Bush told
us about Iraq so I'm going to introduce
Robert Scheer person
Robert Scheer is also a syndicated
columnist and appears in numerous papers
including pre-eminently the Los Angeles
Times
I should say if you could hold your
applause because we want to use the two
hours it in so far as is humanly
possible to do everything we can to
combat the soundbite culture of our time
so the time is precious and we want to
preserve it for as much discussion as we
can I'd also ask you to turn off all
cells and pagers as well next to mr.
Scheer is marked Danner
a staff writer for The New Yorker since
1990 he is reported from a variety of
places around the world Central America
Haiti Bosnia and most recently four from
Iraq for the New York Review of Books
he's just back as a matter of fact from
from Haiti as well he's the author of
the massacre at el mozote a he's the
Henry Luce professor at Bard College
when he is not also working as professor
of journalism at the Graduate School of
Journalism at UC Berkeley he is also the
author in August of the forthcoming book
entitled provocatively the road to
illegitimate C Michael Ignatieff is car
professor of human rights policy at
Harvard University he is also the author
most recently of the lesser evil
political ethics in an age of Terror and
Christopher Hitchens is a well-known
polemicist a vigorous voice on all
matters and who insists on marching to
the beat of his own drummer he's the
author most recently of why Orwell
matters and provocatively and we hope
accurately the long short war that
postponed liberation of Iraq he is also
a contributing writer to Vanity Fair and
the author of numerous books including
the re-release of a book entitled blood
class and Empire being published by
nation books
we'll begin with Christopher and will
simply ask the obvious question were we
right to get into Iraq
thank you Steve congratulations on your
Kim jong-il eminence on the podium it's
the white flag of surrender it will be
it'll be my submission it is my
submission that the case for the removal
by force of the Saddam Hussein regime
was complete in all its essential terms
long before George Bush became president
and this is because it confronted us
then as it does now with the related
problems that arise from first the rogue
state and second the failed state these
two phenomena in separately or in
combination are the two greatest
problems facing the post-cold war world
and they had met their soma in
Mesopotamia some related ambiguities
arise from this duality I think the
first question is did one go in too
early rather than too late and which
pretext or justification for this was it
in our interests or in the interests of
the Iraqi people or both was the
conflict with Saddam Hussein inevitable
or justifiable was it optional was it in
other words elective it seems to me
perfectly self-evident that a
confrontation with Saddam Hussein had
been inevitable at least since 1991 that
it would probably be a good thing if
this confrontation in its timing was
chosen by us rather than as on all
previous occasions of crisis left to
Saddam Hussein to select there wasn't in
other words much of an elective element
about this nor was the very thing novel
or post 9/11 about it it was the oldest
problem on the political agenda of the
United States the regime-change case is
based on both these considerations
Saddam Hussein's regime met all the
preconditions for a removal it had
sacrificed its sovereignty by committing
all four of the violations that can lead
to that sacrifice these are to refresh
your memories violations of the Genocide
Convention repeated invasions of
neighboring countries including the
abolition not just the occupation but
the
of a member state of United Nations
Kuwait repeated violations of the
non-proliferation treaty and a steady
consistent relationship with the gangs
of international nihilism
terrorism and jihad Aslam those are the
four conditions under which the United
Nations can say that a state has
forfeited its its rights Saddam Hussein
had met them all generously and serially
and repeatedly as well as debauching the
entire Treasury of a very important
country and privatizing it as the Prez
the property of his family and his party
of the two most controversial of the
ones I've just mentioned the weaponry
and the terrorism the best evidence has
in fact surfaced since the intervention
as you'll find if you look into the
David Kaye report as recently as March
of last year one month before the
intervention Saddam Hussein's people
were meeting in Damascus with Kim
jong-il though his representatives I
mean to try and buy weapons off the
shelf in production line form from North
Korea the North Koreans finally walked
on this negotiation keeping their
deposit I'm proud to say because there
were too many coalition forces arriving
in the area they thought it was too hot
to continue with this plan and second on
the matter of terrorism the discovery
thanks to the party to the great efforts
of the Kurdish military intelligence in
capturing the memorandum of mr. bin
Laden's deputy mr. sack are we calling
for a religious sectarian war between
Sunni and Shia in Iraq as the means of
defeating American plans at that to the
fact that the main man in the World
Trade Center bombing of 1994 was an
honored guests in Iraq until last April
and had been ever since his arraignment
and that case as well as the weaponry
case seems to me to have been
demonstrated partly by the intervention
itself when people tell you as they
probably will certainly often do that
there are people in this administration
even who used to be indifferent to or
even quite friendly to Saddam was saying
they inadvertently make the same point
that I making this recognition is a
belated one when it came belatedly
anyone who was prepared to
look the four conditions that I just
mentioned or to relax them was in effect
asking us to give soon I was saying the
benefit of the doubt to give him the
presumption of innocence there is no
sensible way anybody could argue in
favor of that proposition I was and
remain a great friend of the Vietnamese
Revolution and I don't like to see my
Vietnamese friends insulted so I won't
say any more on this point except that
if you really want to wind the feelings
of the Vietnamese and if you really want
to defame their long struggle against
partition and occupation and for
independence just compare them to the
pharaoh haman saddam or to the car mania
store were hobbyists and bandits who are
now ravaging parts of Iraq Iraq is not a
Vietnam it's on a giant scale what would
have happened in Yugoslavia what was
nearly allowed to happen in Yugoslavia
or Somalia or Rwanda but in a in a
gigantically more horrible way just for
once it was decided to assume this heavy
responsibility in advance to realize
that we had inherited a broken bankrupt
terrorized traumatized maimed Iraq so
that we wouldn't now or a little later
we're having an inquest into how did
Iraq implode how did it go into the
black hole how did it become a Rwanda
who who was in charge watching this
happen what she'd go through the eclipse
of Saddam Hussein himself through the
delicious period that would have been
the guy who Sai Hussein interregnum and
the ensuing stirring up of ethnic tribal
and religious hatred interventions of
opportunity by outside powers like
Turkey Iran in Saudi Arabia all of this
was coming unless a coalition could be
put together to put the country in trust
and if you don't believe me one was
asked the chief of bureaucratic
precedence and current moral hero
Richard Clarke whose advice that
consistently was through the Clinton
administration to leave Rwanda alone and
let it run and who hasn't yet managed to
apologize I notice for that though there
he did have a responsibility now mr.
Clarke and others have made it appear
sinister
that anyone could possibly care about
Iraq before 9/11 to be found to have
mentioned Saddam Hussein as a threat
that might have to be dealt with before
that date or even immediately afterwards
is practically and conviction for
conspiracy at present instead of what it
really is something praiseworthy it was
a desire and a readiness to shoulder
that responsibility to put an end to the
horror of the sanctions regime which was
punishing the Iraqi people while
enriching their oppressors to continue
the honor of the no-fly zones that had
protected northern and southern Iraq the
Kurdish and Shia populations from
further attentions from helicopter
gunships and death squads to put an end
in other words to the state of affairs
where Iraq was half-slave and half-free
and where but the official West and the
United Nations were running it in
collusion with Saddam Hussein that
status quo was neither defensible nor
feasible nor would it have lasted and
all of that or most of it was clear by
the year 2000 if not before but after
the dramatic declaration of jihad
against our society in September 2001 I
think we can say the matter became more
stark it was possible perhaps to
consider persisting in limited police
actions like the arrest of the World
Trade Center bombers of 94 their
successful trial or the tit-for-tat
retaliations that occasionally took
place after the bombing of an embassy
here the sinking of a American ship
there but even those police actions the
limited as they were demanded regime
change in Afghanistan after 2001 in
Afghanistan is now in nature
responsibility and I do not believe the
fans of mr. bin Laden and there's
nostalgia for the Taliban will succeed
in defeating or consider succeeding who
considered defeating the largest and
most sophisticated military alliance the
world has ever seen al-qaeda as a crime
family is finished as a bent
multinational corporation it's been
closed down as a guerrilla group it has
it the most two of its prominent leaders
still at Liberty this only leaves us
therefore with the problem of what to do
about jihad in general and if it seems
to me very plain
there the urgent need was and is to
alter the balance of power in the region
against the forces of jihad there is a
civil war going on in the Islamic world
and those who are on the jihad side of
it hope to win this war intimidate
terrorize and bankrupt and enslave their
own societies in other words by
exporting this war to our society in
this they must not be allowed to succeed
we have to intervene in that Civil War
make sure it goes the other way they say
they'd like to change our society in our
regime our replies no you will not be
allowed to do that but we will change
yours that's the only possible or
correct response very important in the
change of government in Iraq is this
once the Iraqi oil industry is up and
running again which will be thanks to
the excellent efforts of Halliburton in
others you laugh you laugh but who would
you like to see in charge of the Iraqi
or who would you was it not privatized
when it was the personal property of
Saddam Hussein's family which it will be
when Iraqi oil as I repeat is up and
running as an industry again it will it
will have more and better oil than Saudi
Arabia does the Saudi oil monopoly the
relative strength of the Saudi Arabia
and its Wahhabi oligarchy currently
exert on the world oil market will be
sensibly diminished that's good in my
opinion right I'm gonna be judgemental
and simplistic about this that's a good
thing the depraved mullahs of Iraq who
after a quarter of a century have
beggared and ruined their country and
have become discredited of Iran excuse
me of Iran who after a quarter of a
century in power reduced their country
to nothingness and lost all their credit
with their population have also been put
on notice they've been forced to concede
that they've been cheating on the
non-proliferation treaty don't tell me
that these concessions and these
admissions would not have been wrung
from them if it wasn't for the stand
taken by the coalition in Iraq and
they've been forced to share their hand
in preventing the holding of a decent
election or even a parody of one in
their own country and their days are
evidently numbered and not even mr.
Schirach is going to be making any more
excuses for them on the question of the
weapons of mass destruction all of these
are pluses they show that the regime
change ethos
is effective and workable in the region
as well as essential to the people who
live there and to us also there's a very
interesting argument about what might
have been done differently or better and
I like this argument and I've been
taking part in it I tend to agree with
my friend Ahmed Chalabi that it would
have been a good thing to have elections
earlier and to transfer of sovereignty
sooner I think I still agree with him
that de-baathification is more important
than continuity in the professional and
police and military services there are
many other things that might have been
done better or differently or better
prepared for but do not ladies and
gentlemen brothers and sisters comrades
do not try and persuade yourself and do
not try and persuade anybody else
now the outbreak of banditry and
thuggery in certain parts of Iraq is the
consequence of any mistake made by the
coalition do not it's you know think of
it as the expression of a patriotic
grievance do not refer to these fascists
and sadists as insurgents or rebels this
is a well-organized attempt by the
losing side by the war harvest and
Romania factions now working in
collusion and working in collusion with
the four-bath regime to prevent a
democratic transformation of the country
thank you very much Christopher I'll
have more to say if you press me
it's a stop mark dinner we'll speak next
recently returned from Iraq thank you
Steve
Americans dream dreams we wouldn't be
Americans if we didn't dream dreams and
Iraq is a dream that for most of the
country has turned into a nightmare
there are a few people who resolutely
refused to look at what's going on on
the ground at what is happening every
day in front of them on their television
screens and in their newspapers and
there are some people who it's
completely clear there is nothing that
could happen in Iraq that would suggest
to them that the war was a bad idea and
has hurt American interests and has in
fact made Americans less safe rather
than safer I've debated now with
Christopher I think this is the sixth
time and or is it eight or is it 10 I
don't remember in any event it's very
clear to me that like our president
george w bush there's nothing that could
happen in iraq that could persuade him
that the invasion and occupation of this
country was a mistake even though today
as we stand here gathered together 13
months after we were last together
debating in los angeles we are living we
are enduring the worst and bloodiest
month of the war now christopher didn't
mention this in fact he hardly if you
will notice spoke about the war at all
he talked about what might have happened
if it wasn't for he talked about the
reasons for it which was a rehearsal of
reasons many of which you've heard
before ad nauseam but which very few
people are citing anymore though he
didn't raise weapons of mass destruction
he didn't talk about what's actually
going on on the ground and I feel it's
absolutely vital for us as Americans in
an election year to take a look at this
war that we are embroiled in that is
getting worse as we speak on this fine
day in April that will continue to get
worse
and for which there is no plan to
extract us and no plan to protect the
American interests that this
administration by its decision to fight
a war of convenience not of necessity
has put at risk this is a chart from the
Luna Vil org site it lists casualties
American allied and others and you'll
see that after the initial months of the
war where you had 65 dead 73 dead of
dead americans I'm talking about not
Iraqis and then it declined to the
mid-40s this is when President Bush took
his prance across the aircraft carrier
just off the southern california coast
and declared mission accomplished
we had numbers of death down numbers of
death up spiking in November to 82
Americans dead
this was the Ramadan offensive when I
was in Iraq and now as we speak as of
yesterday a hundred and twelve dead
Americans which works out according to
Luna Vil - almost five a day you should
take a moment to look around this hall
pretty soon I'm told that the bottom
part of this hall holds about 800 or so
people were almost at that point of
young dead Americans in Iraq now
Christopher would say as with President
Bush that well people die in war and you
exploit this issue by holding up this
chart the fact is though that more
people are dying this month than died in
the month after we debated here and the
policy in the future is based on a
series of dreams dreams dreams of a
broad coalition dreams of Iraqi security
services dreams of handing over
sovereignty one can summarize very
briefly the Iraq war and the events that
led up to it first the administration
and those who argued relentlessly for
war a war that didn't need to be fought
relentlessly exaggerated the risk that
Iraq and Saddam Hussein posed to the
United States and its interests second
those who argued for a war of
convenience the administration and those
who backed it like Christopher and
others argued relentlessly understated
relentlessly I should put it the risks
of fighting that war the risks of
occupying Iraq invading and occupying
Iraq let's talk a bit about this
Christopher went through many of the
same arguments although he conspicuously
left out the weapons of mass destruction
which is twice not to exist that's twice
- please let me finish and no one can
respond when your time comes around
again if you please the president called
it a grave and gathering threat at the
last debate we had here there was a
general disparagement on the part of
Christopher and others disparagement of
Blake's
Chirac Mohamed ElBaradei and others who
were doing inspections in Iraq though
the argument seems to be on
Christopher's part that the regime was
about to implode his word and that no
war would be necessary by the way
because the implosion would make any war
strictly unnecessary in fact there was
no evidence that the regime was
imploding and when we last met here
hundreds of his inspectors were on the
ground in Iraq trying to find the
elusive weapons of mass destruction
troops were on the border Saddam was in
his box he posed no threat to the United
States it had been determined absolutely
convincingly that there was no nuclear
program in Iraq the International Atomic
Energy Agency had shown that something
that we knew before and many of these
things by the way that seemed like
revelations now we knew before the war
was fought we knew it which is one of
the reasons why the last couple of
months as we've seen books by Blix by
Richard Clark now by Bob Woodward's have
felt like to those who followed the war
closely are the beginnings very closely
like a bad movie played in Reverse
because these things are not revelations
they're things that we as American
citizens knew about so you had generally
it was generally accepted that Saddam
might have some weapons of mass
destruction might have some chemical
weapons might have some biological
weapons many intelligence services
accepted this the administration
doggedly using a number of props like
the aluminum tubes like the non-existent
uranium from Africa exaggerated this
reality the suspicion into the thought
that as Condoleezza Rice put it The
Smoking Gun might become a mushroom
cloud that is that Saddam would soon get
nuclear weapons no one believed that it
was told to the American people again
and again and again and these claims
were lies we knew that before the war we
know it now and we should think about
this in this election year we should
think about the damage done not only to
American security but the damage done to
American democracy by the process by
which this president and this
administration took us to war now we
went to war the the greatest catastrophe
I think of going to war apart from the
war itself and the worsening conditions
in Iraq was the fact that we went
virtually alone we went against the
wishes of the United Nations against the
wishes of our major allies and we went
and it with a kind of isolation that
American policymakers have avoided since
after the Second World War when it was
determined that American power however
great can be maximized only by working
with our allies and by enlisting the
moral approval of the world for our
actions the Bush administration took it
on a upon itself to go dramatically
against this wisdom that had been handed
down by ten presidents we find ourselves
now in a condition of isolation that
everyday is growing worse the Spanish
have withdrawn and their allies other
allies are growing weaker in their
support and the opponents in Iraq the
insurgents rebels whatever you'd like to
call them have played increasingly on
this sense of isolation by attacking
what few allies we have by attacking the
United Nations by attacking the
Jordanian embassy by attacking the Turks
and so on all right the second my second
point was that we were brought to war by
a continual underestimation
understatement of the risks of the
occupation itself the United States went
into this war with a president who told
them that the war would be easy with
administration supporters saying that it
would be a cakewalk with administration
supporters like Christopher saying that
we would be greeted by with flowers and
sweets on the streets of Iraqi cities
and more seriously still by an absolute
failure to anticipate the obvious
political difficulties and putting
together an Iraqi regime that can rule
the country in peace and without
violence Saddam was there for a reason
he was a minority leader of a minority
community in Iraq the Sunnis ruling over
a majority Shiite population the United
States now finds itself in a situation
where it does not know what to do we are
supposed to hand over sovereignty at the
end of June we do not know to whom we
are to hand it over no leaders have been
selected there have been three or four
different plans that have fallen apart
and we have found out in the last few
days that in fact this is going to be
semi some sovereignty or limited
sovereignty that this Iraqi government
that will take shape we don't know from
where we don't know out of whom will not
have the power to make laws will not
have the power to change the laws that
the Americans have passed during their
time there will not have control over
the American forces will not have
control even over the Iraqi security
forces so it's one wonders what exactly
this definition of sovereignty is
meanwhile the political position in Iraq
grows more tenuous by the day the Iraqi
Ministry of Health gave figures for the
number of deaths in Fallujah in the
first two weeks in April they estimated
that more than 800 Iraqis had died in
Fallujah that battle is about to be
rejoined when Iraqis look on their
television sets and see the fighting in
Fallujah they think Jeanine they think
of what happened on the West Bank and
the Israeli incursions there in the
spring of 2002 and it is steadily
whittling down any support for the
occupation within Iraq not to mention in
the broader region christopher talked
about building support
let's see in the region against the
forces of jihad that is this is a
political war in which we must convince
the Arab world the Muslim world that the
United States is on their side and give
them a vision of democracy this is the
the predominant reason for this war
that's been given after the evaporation
of the weapons of mass destruction now
insofar as we can measure the success or
failure of such an elusive goal we can
look at poll results and we can discover
for example that in our closest ally in
the region Jordan before the war one in
four Jordanians felt favourably toward
the US during the war one percent did
one out of a hundred now five percent do
one out of twenty and there are similar
figures for all of the other countries
throughout the Middle East that is the
feeling toward the United States is
relentlessly and increasingly negative
and the war is making it more so now are
these dreams this notion of spreading
democracy this notion of giving the
region hope or is it something we can
measure in so far as we can measure it
the war has been a catastrophe for
American interests for American approval
in the region and we now see as we stand
here in April absolutely no way out
thank you very much mark dinner
michael ignatieff your thoughts I
supported the war in Iraq essentially
for one reason which is that in 93 1993
I spent three weeks in northern Iraq and
spent time with the Kurds went to
halabja where the Kurds had been gassed
and massacred spoke to Wharf ins and
widows people who'd been killed in
Saddam's on file campaign in 1987 I
supported the war because I wanted to
get rid of a man who'd committed
genocide against people waged two wars
within his region and whether he had the
capabilities that the Bush
administration came certainly had the
intention to acquire capabilities that
would threaten the region and the world
I went back to Iraq two weeks ago I went
to the northern Iraqi region also known
as Kurdistan and what I saw was this I
saw 25% of the Iraqi population that is
the Kurds live better have better roads
have better schools I've got an airport
have had 10 years of self-government
under the protection of United States
and British forces
please remember that I'm not going to
deny how how difficult it is in Iraq now
but do come out of this morning
remembering that for five million Iraqis
for people who've been massacred and
gassed and pushed around life is
concretely in simple and obvious ways
better in April 2004 than it was last
year and certainly better than it was in
1993 okay that's the first thing I want
to tell you the second thing I want to
tell you is about pre-emptive war and
about the case for war I think you can
only make a case for pre-emptive war and
I think you have
to make a case for pre-emptive war
because we can't wait to be struck we
have to take pre-emptive military action
that part of the bush case I actually
accept we then as citizens of a
democracy have to think about how you
regulate pre-emptive war I think you can
only do so when the threat is imminent I
can think secondly that you can only use
imminent pre-emptive force as a last
resort and third most important you have
to have the Democratic consent of the
people now here's where because I'm not
interested in a kind of tit-for-tat with
that side I'm not interested in lining
up with Chris although I substantive ly
support his position but let's be honest
about my position I supported the war
and I supported pre-emptive war but the
threat was not imminent we had not
achieved last resort in diplomacy
although I think you could make a case
that we were almost there and the most
troubling aspect which trouble is every
one of us and troubles me frankly is the
issue of democratic consent
I've made the case that I would make for
war which is we need to get rid of a
genocide 'el tyrant who's a risk to the
neighborhood and who is not threatening
us now but sure as sunday is today is
going to threaten us down the road an
honest case for this war this is my
problem
an honest case for the war that says the
threat is not imminent but it's coming
down the pike and we got to stop this
tyrant before he hits us that case I'm
not sure would have persuaded the
American people that's the trouble on my
side to be honest with you
in other words mark downer is right when
he says that the threat was exaggerated
that is not good for democracy that's
bad for democracy one of the one of the
things that has cost my side an enormous
amount of legitimacy in this argument is
the people who made the case fiddled
with the truth and
I'm not going to be part to that
okay now where are we now let me just I
don't know where we are now but let me
let me let me tell you let me tell you
where we are not okay we are not in the
middle of a civil war there is an
insurgency in the South led by one
militia he's making a power grab in a
political vacuum to win support with the
Shia it's not a civil war he is using
his loot raising a militia to make a
preemptive strike against the
pre-eminence
the Iraqi cleric Ali Sistani it's a
battle for power it is not a generalized
civil war secondly we are not in we are
not in a general insurrection against
the American occupation there is a
pocket a really nasty scary pocket I
don't want to deny the seriousness of
this in Fallujah these are tribal clan
based groups with foreign fighters and
xpath is fighting the transition to
democracy they must be beaten I don't
quite know how I don't want to have our
soldiers fighting in the streets of
Fallujah I prefer to strangle this
slowly take our time but they do not
resent represent the whole of the Iraqi
people what we know from poll data is
one they don't want us here they don't
want to be occupied no sensible people
want to be occupied but they know but
they know that the only people holding
the security situation together are all
our American forces they need American
forces there to transition towards
democratic self-rule these people
supporters of muqtada al-sadr and the
insurgents in Fallujah do not I believe
I'm not making
ideological point here I'm making an
empirical point do not I believe speak
for the Iraqi people who simply want to
get on with their daily lives elect a
government of their own choosing and get
us out and run their own country and
control the oil in their own name that
seems to me a perfectly worthy and
useful goal third so it's not a civil
war it is not a general insurrection
against American power and third it's
not Vietnam it's not Vietnam because
we're not facing the massed divisions of
an enemy State we are not facing a
coherent nationalist communist ideology
and we are not going to lose 58,000
troops finally we are not in a quagmire
because there is this is the only place
I'd agree with Martin disagree with Mark
Downer directly we we do have an exit
strategy Lakhdar Brahimi works with the
Iraqis to choose a transitional
administration it takes power on the 1st
of July I don't like any more than Mark
Danner the rubbish coming out of
Washington to the effect that these
people shouldn't have any real power
they must have real power it's their
country not ours
that's number one number two they work
towards a Constituent Assembly in
January 2005 that constituencies
Assembly drafts a final Constitution at
the end of 2005 there are general
elections we may not like the result but
that is a trajectory towards a
democratic transition ok so there is an
exit strategy here and it's absolutely
crucial that those timelines be kept -
and that the faith that we have in
democracy as a people is expressed in
our faith in their capacity to become a
democracy
finally just so we know how much trouble
we're in look at these candidates that
you have to choose from this November
number one you've got a president who
fought endlessly about phase one two and
three of the military plan and delayed
planning for phase four namely what you
do once you've taken the country he
delayed it so long and allowed so much
confusion to develop that we went into
an occupation without a plan we need
lessly lost American and Iraqi lives
because simple administrative and
executive failures by our chief
executive he didn't understand the
Pottery Barn principle of modern
politics you know the Pottery Barn
principle you break it you own it right
on that basis alone this man may have
forfeited your confidence I say no more
about the president because I'm not
making a party political thing I got
nothing but bad things to say about all
of them number
number two number two we've got another
candidate Ralph Nader he has a plan the
plan the plan consists in speedy
withdrawal that's part of plan a plan B
is reelect George Bush but the worst
news my friends is about candidate
number three because when asked what
John Kerry would do about Iraq he says
go to the United Nations
internationalize where Mark Tanner's
entirely right is the internationals are
rightly heading for the exit because
they understand the Pottery Barn
principle we broke it we own it
and we have to fix it John Kerry does
not have a plan he wants to
internationalize something he wants to
get the UN involved the UN is already
involved Lakhdar Brahimi is pulling our
coals from the fire as we speak god
bless him but the UN can't take over the
assignment here we need to follow the
exit trajectory that I defined a minute
ago we need to stick to it we need to
drive it if we believe in democracy we
need to transfer responsibility to the
Iraqis we need to make good on a promise
we didn't come here to occupy and
tyrannize we came here to liberate we
just better well damn well do it thank
you
Robert Scheer hi first of all it's a
good sign that someone much younger than
myself would get my name wrong because I
would be really scared if I had made an
error like that I I do want to say
however my son Christopher sure did
actually write this book and I am
getting credit for it so that's terrific
I hoped that would happen some point in
life and it has and the book the five
biggest lies Bush told us about Iraq is
depressingly accurate and has held up
were not not the case trust me I would
not be Hawking it I would not be signing
it I would not be speaking here except
in a deeply confessional tone if the
United States had gone in and found
weapons that the UN inspectors would not
have found if they found the scientists
who are not free to talk but now told us
where those weapons were if they had
found the links to September 11th and to
al-qaeda if they had found the drones
that could unleash these weapons on our
country if they had found this nuclear
weapons industry that congolese one
could be The Smoking Gun a mushroom
cloud over Chicago in New York had they
found any one of those points I would be
deeply shameful for the way I work I
would question my methodology I would
wonder what had happened to me in my
common sense and the fact forgetting
about other members of this panel the
fact that the neoconservatives the
people who drove this policy who
supported it in and outside the
administration have not a single moment
of doubts hesitation self-examination is
to my mind truly alarming and
even Tony Blair is quoted in the
Woodward book with smoke to burst
Parliament said that he had doubts when
he saw the bodies coming home our
president doesn't want us allow us see
pictures of coffins how can we make
decisions about war peace if we can't
see pictures of coffins if we can't look
at the consequence
how dare a president in a democratic
society tell us that we cannot look at
the dead and wounded we cannot study and
we cannot know the stats it's ridiculous
how can we make a decision without
knowing the ultimate ultimate
implication of those actions and when we
were asked Bush do you have the doubts
that Tony Blair expressed Tony Blair
said when he got those letters from
people whose kids had been killed
somebody's kids are just barely out of
high school got killed in Iraqi said of
course I have doubts our president said
no doubts no doubts and I could tell
that to the public it's alarming now
unfortunately we don't have a
representative of the Bush
administration on his panel Christopher
may represent Shalaby but he Shalaby
does not seem to have much of a
following in the country he seems to be
in the process of being bypassed and the
new coalition that will represent all
Iraqis and I must say I don't think
Christopher would make a very good
representative for this administration
because as far as I can see the sauce
the reason for going to this war since
the president admits in Woodward's book
very clearly and they haven't denied
this gave him more time than he gave any
other reporter the president admits that
he found the so-called evidence of
weapons of mass destruction to be paltry
would not convince John pew Q public and
will not convince him he and it's also
admitted in the Woodward but there were
no links to al-qaeda to bin Laden so the
whole justification of the war but
there's this international terror force
that because of the terrible tragedy of
9/11 we had to bait and switch to use
Colin Powell's words and take attention
away from Afghanistan take attention
away from the war on terror
not examiner at all Stonewall any
investigation in fact in a point a man
that Christopher I don't think admire is
very much Henry Kissinger to lead this
investigation so in Christopher Edwards
a war criminal to lead our investigation
of the biggest tragedy that's happened
in this country and then Stonewall it
meant this administration did not want
to know about this tragedy but instead
wanted to exploit it to deceive the
American people to con them into another
adventure that they had on their mind
from day one as Paul O'Neill as Clarke
and as the Woodward book amply confirmed
we are at a Book Festival books are the
first draft of history and we have
damning evidence that the American
people will lie to in a dramatic fashion
the representative democracy was mocked
in an extreme way and not only did we
give the back of the hands to the United
Nations which we created more than any
other country
we gave the back of the hand to any
other democratic society that did where
the leader did follow the wishes of the
voters we said the Germans are must have
the wrong DNA to be warriors they're
just ultimate pacifists we said the
French would not ever dare be
colonialist ignoring in the Battle of
Algiers and their years in Indochina and
now the Spanish oh well they're just
wimps because they dared elect somebody
who would do what 90% of the people
wanted to do all along not go into Iraq
so the biggest tragedy and this whole
thing the biggest cost the reason why it
was wrong to go in is that we never used
to believe the ends justify the means
now those of us on the left when we have
made errors it's precisely because we
believe the end justify the means that's
the lesson we should have learned from
our history the fact is if you use that
noble means you will end up with a noble
ends that's what we're seeing in Iraq it
doesn't matter what you state after the
fact secondly what we're seeing is that
the American people will not ultimately
and this is the Vietnam analogy if you
like will not ultimately they yes
they're patriotic yes they wanted to
friend the country yes they want to
fight terror but once they get the idea
that they've been lied to they won't
follow
they won't needlessly sacrifice their
young they won't pay for the cost of
this and in objecting they will be doing
their patriotic duty that's what they'll
be doing so it seems to me the real cost
of this war the real issue is that we
held up a model of democracy that we
wanted to sell to the world a model of
limited government checks and balances
of Free Press and we will even impose
that on the world from time to time and
what did we do we shame that model we
disgraced that model more than any enemy
of democracy could ever do
and be best if you hold your applause
because from previous experience that
will only cause Hitchens to attack the
audience and we'll forget about the
whole subject so forget forget the
applause well some people will clap in
it but but I think that is the serious
issue here we had and it's Democrats and
Republicans Congress is supposed to wage
war Congress is supposed to allocate
funds we know now about the 700 million
dollars
we know that 72 days after 9/11 this
President took his Secretary of Defense
aside and said let's go after Iraq and
use funds that was supposed to be going
to fight the Taliban in Afghanistan I
was think that would be a crime that
would get somebody impeached more than a
[ __ ]
we know we know that this administration
didn't care about the war on terror we
know that from from what not only the
inside books but from their actions
let's go even further when the Clinton
administration which is now attacked for
being wishy-washy and so forth and I
have my own criticisms but the fact is
when they sent those cruise missiles in
Clinton was attacked for this wag the
dog scenario of a distracting our
attention from the important business of
Monica Lewinsky let's not forget that
and the people who were then beating up
on Clinton didn't make the arguments now
that are made against criticizing the
president they didn't say you're
weakening the president United States by
going into his sex life or the phony
whitewater scandal which you hounded
with him from the first day they didn't
say anything of the sort they didn't
care about this terrorism and when this
new administration came in and was
informed by sandy Berger and others
about this problem as being the most
pressing what did they do they ignored
it and let me say something we hear a
lot of attacks on the left on the peace
movement and so forth which by the way
got it right 15 million people around
the world protest against this war they
were right they didn't need it big
sources you know didn't have to be big
experts okay but what group warned us of
something this administration never
seemed to grasp that bin Laden and the
Taliban were one in the same and were a
horrible Menace guess what group it
wasn't the Hawks
it wasn't the neoconservatives it wasn't
Paul Wolfowitz it wasn't the right wing
no it was the foundation for a feminist
majority peg Yorkin Mavis Leno people
like that and for five years they made a
movie called behind the shroud that
people smuggled into Afghanistan and for
five years they tried to warn us about
this monster of our creation by the way
the Mujahideen that we had brought to
Afghanistan and the holy war against
communism the people we as supplies
thing or rockets to the people that we
had called in battle plans
by the way as long as we're mentioning
the crimes of Saddam Hussein I'm sick
and tired of hearing this thing from the
President and others about the genocide
of Sodom saying yes the guy was a
genocide or killer a monster so forth
he's a secular genocide a pillow a
monster let's not forget that he was an
enemy of bin Laden but leaving that
aside this constant referenced by this
president he used weapons of mass
destruction against his own people
when will the media ask this president
if that's the case and he used them in
1987 he even used them before Rumsfeld
went there and shook hands with him he
used them before you know we were giving
massive aid in fact those mass graves
existed back then before your father
extended 1.2 billion dollars in credit
to this mass murderer now why do you
come back a decade later with a defined
leader who by the way could not control
the Kurdish area which was protected and
if you're gonna liberate those Kurds he
got Kurds in Turkey and elsewhere you
better watch what you start but they
weren't being threatened and the fact of
the matter is this an excuse it's
another way of lying so we try to figure
out what motivates this administration
and I don't want to get personal here
but I think Christopher is a poor
representative because my reading of the
literature is that there's an appeal to
an almighty okay so after Kissinger we
have the almighty another group that
that Christopher has not taken to defend
much now I will admit when I first saw
Woodward on 60 minutes I wrote a column
I fought the almighty being referred to
he said it's a higher he didn't talk to
his father who knew a lot he didn't talk
to Brent Scowcroft he said I talked to a
higher father you know that's in the way
but not tonight I thought he meant some
kind of notion of God Almighty it turns
out on reading the book he really meant
Cheney
because there is not really a scene in
this book where Chaney is not present
and as long as we're mentioning I'm
sorry the end on this as long as we're
mentioning chained I didn't see let
apologize you take it out my time after
as long as we mention Chaney and Powell
don't forget one thing in Powell's
comments in the Woodward book edition
that if it's broke you own it he said
our Vice President had a fever that's a
sign of deranged a fever that he
wouldn't let go of to go after Iraq and
our president caught that fever that's
the scary thing that happened
may I make a simple request I know that
it is tempting for some to applaud
sentiments with which you agree it is
more difficult to applaud sentiments
that challenge presumptions and
prejudices you may have entered the hall
with but it may even be more difficult
to be mindful of a very large audience
that is now watching this program thanks
to the considerable generosity of c-span
so I ask please hold your applause until
the end will now have rebuttal
christopher hitchens well so I just
forced me to say this ladies and
gentlemen you are slightly too easily
pleased I think and too easily amused to
and I've I was of course bearing in mind
the the sober calm c-span audience in my
remarks I wasn't bidding for any
affection from you lot just a factual
point of rebuttal I hope you'll bear me
out this far I did refer twice to the
attempt by the Saddam Hussein regime as
late as last March to acquire weapons of
mass destruction and the means of
delivering them off the shelf from North
Korea you can read it all in the David
Kaye report it's very fascinating a
piece of work Hans Blix would never have
found that out by the way so I have to
resent marked down as saying I didn't
touch upon this question we wouldn't
know about this also that disc and
related documents hadn't been captured
during the intervention bear in mind
also that not even Blix will be able to
tell you that Saddam Hussein ever came
into compliance with the most decisive
of the UN resolutions and this fetish of
the United Nations I think deserves a
little reconsideration in light of the
fact of the double-dealing done by two
veto power members of the Security
Council of France and Russia and in what
seems to be a very unpleasant unfolding
scandal about the administration of the
UN oil-for-food program I don't like
being teased or jeered at about the
Iraqi people's reception and flourish
people's reception of the liberation
forces I did see everywhere I went
people of all ages and conditions
welcoming and greeting and showering
American and British and other forces
with gratitude and I shall never forget
it and I shall never abandon those
people either and I I resent the tone of
those who can't wait to to do so when I
first heard the Pottery Barn analogy
which was a I think from that great
stateswoman
Maureen Dowd in her column I first
thought it was unpardonably flippant but
on reconsideration I'm more inclined to
take the line that michael ignatieff des
does about it there with a different
emphasis remember the motto the mantra
you break it you earn it I hate to keep
on about this but all of this was
decided before the name George Bush
could be brought into play in other
words to play on the feelings of those
who don't like the president by 1998
when the Senate had passed the Iraq
liberation act without a single
dissenting vote and after a very long
deliberation that it should be the
policy of the United States to remove
the government of Saddam Hussein not
only was Iraq very badly broken
extremely badly broken maimed shattered
under sanctions as well as under
political terror and the threat of a new
genocide but we also already owned it
we'd had we had we had inherited that
responsibility those sanctions were ours
there was no alternative to having them
the terrible thing was to collude with
Bertha's sanctions and the regime and
have to patrol the north in the south
from the air being fired on every day a
virtual declaration of war as it was
Iraq was already broken and it was
already ours and I will repeat this as
long as I have to long before any cheap
jokes can be made by or about Richard
Clark or Dick Cheney or Paul Wolfowitz
and the acceptance of that
responsibility is the test of
seriousness not just of our leaders and
our politicians but it's a test of
seriousness for you ladies and gentlemen
as citizens and voters and I wish you
did
I wish you'd face it a little more
sterically because that's where we are
now how much longer do you have like to
let it run would you like to see what
the you dicus a regime would have been
like would you fact
see the death throes of a regime that
lived by divide and rule and stirring up
sectarian and ethnic hatred there would
have been a Fallujah all across Iraq if
that had happened and there would have
been no one to arrest it now what's
happening at present the pilgrimages the
Hajj has been restored to this year they
can go to their holy cities again the
Sunni Iraqis can go across the border to
Saudi Arabia Mecca and Medinah again a
year ago it was death to do that it was
as dangerous as to have a satellite dish
in the nazarene district of southern
Iraq last week during the pilgrimage and
also during for the unpleasantness in in
the JAF there were municipal elections
in 17 major towns husbands and wives
were issued different colored version
cards so that wives could go and vote at
its time of their choosing didn't have
to be brought by their husbands the
Islamic parties did very well in all
these places
good grief is that my time but the
secular parties won there quite clearly
and quite freely that's what the jihad
people want to prevent from happening we
should be very plain about this and if
we have underestimated their venom and
if there are more of them than we
thought there were well that's fine
because who will look me in the eye and
say we haven't been at war with these
people and looking for ways to find and
kill and isolate and defeat and destroy
them these many years and only Howard
Dean it seems to me would have the nerve
to say that there was no jihad problem
in Iraq and so we got there to blame the
jihad on us this ridiculous masochism of
this other sort of people who call the
jihadists insurgents and when you're
done with Deen you have a democratic
candidate whose indecision is apparently
final we will now turn to mark Danner
for a brief rebuttal well the fact is
that Iraq is on its way on its way to
becoming the next Afghanistan and when I
say that I mean that it's becoming the
cause of jihadist forces around the
Middle East and around the Islamic world
to go to Iraq if you want to fight the
Americans if you want to fight jihad if
you want to do these things you slip
across the border in Syria Saudi Arabia
you
Ron and join the jihad forces and it's
becoming a rallying cry of the nine of
the excuse me of the new century similar
to the way that Afghanistan was the
rallying cry of the 1980s for jihad
forces then which gave birth to of
course al-qaeda and Osama bin Laden one
of the reasons that Fallujah has been
boiling the way it has one of the
reasons why you've had suicide bombings
across the country is because not just
because of indigenous elements but
because of foreign jihad fighters coming
into the country now what does that mean
it simply means that the the cause that
Christopher's set forth and that the
administration has the political cause
the notion that after 9/11 we have to
change their view we have to give the
Middle East hope we have to show that
there's a democratic way has been stood
on its head and the US and invading Iraq
and occupying it in invading and
occupying a major Arab country the
second-largest oil reserves in the world
has done the opposite of what it seems
to have planned which is give Democratic
hope to the region instead it's given
the opposite view there was a piece in
The New York Times the other day
Thursday battle for Fallujah arouses the
anger of Iraqis weary of the u.s.
occupation it's a fascinating piece Edie
Wong walked along the main shopping
street of Baghdad our outer karada
karada which is like may as well be
Times Square in New York and talk to
people who should be the main US main
supporters of the United States my
opinion of the Americans has changed one
store owner said when the Americans came
they talked about freedom and democracy
now the Americans are pushing their
views by force all of us feel that and
The Times reporter after coming up with
many of these quotes as people like mr.
Wakile and mr. Hussein are the kind of
middle-class Iraqis that the Americans
are relying on to help them rebuild the
country with livelihoods already rooted
in the spirit of free market capitalism
yet their sense of kinship with Iraqis
in Fallujah Najaf and elsewhere runs
deeper than any pull toward abstract
notions of democracy offered by the
Americans notions that to them appear
increasingly hypocritical
given the reliance of the occupiers on
overwhelming force as a means to an end
now I want to take issue with something
that Michael said I agreed with a lot of
what he said there's no total
insurrection in Iraq there is a growing
rebellion there is no complete
insurrection among shiite there's part
of a rebellion there i think it'll get
worse i said in a debate with
christopher in january that it get worse
and it indeed has michael said that he
talked he talked about the trajectory of
an exit strategy don't worry we have an
exit strategy don't worry we have
elections planned don't worry it's a
step-by-step plan take a look at it well
you know we've had several of these
plans and time and again we have missed
these deadlines because and this is the
only way iraq is like vietnam we have a
military operation that is sinking into
a political quicksand
there is no political basis for it there
is no political plan there is no way out
that suggests a way to put a rock back
together again we can talk about
elections in january but if if the
fighting continues the way it is there
is nothing more vulnerable than
elections in the polls in 1987 in haiti
a couple hundred people were killed
you get people gathering on the street
and suicide bombers you'll have a lot of
people killed you need some sort of
consensus to stage elections and
elections and handing over power is the
only way america can get out of iraq and
it is unclear now how exactly it's going
to do it so the confidence in this plan
that we're talking about is i think
another way of dreaming dreams and we're
seeing those dreams melt in front of us
the first was they would recognize as
liberty liberators weapons of mass
destruction the grand alliance which
which never a grand alliance of the
willing but is now getting smaller and
smaller the Iraqi security forces taking
over power you know we hear again and
again these numbers about the Iraqi army
I have a quote again from this weekend's
USA Today an American general talking
about his forces melting away in
Fallujah when they faced the enemy and
they refused to fight this is Iraqi
forces
this is Major General Paul Eden
quote what I had was a battalion that
just didn't understand why they were
engaged by their own people these were
the Iraqi army the new Iraqi army put on
by the Americans just didn't understand
why they were fighting Iraqis that
doesn't point to a future and an exit
strategy the kind of exit strategy that
Michael very optimistically described to
you Michael Ignatieff I I would like to
emphasize something that Christopher
Hitchens said earlier which is take
let's take our responsibilities here
many of the criticisms made by Bob
Scheer and Mark Downer
are it seems to be pertinent there are
good descriptions of a bad situation but
then the question becomes what do we do
here that the tone in mark Downers
rebuttal to you is essentially almost as
if I opposed the war so it's not my
responsibility
and I just think we're that's not where
we are now we're in a situation this is
the pottery of armed problem we have a
responsibility now to make it work it
seems to me to be of course their
problems with this election trajectory
that I outlined to you of course it's
difficult I mean what what's the
substance of what Mark is telling you
yes it's difficult it's very very
difficult but consider the alternatives
here we have to the point is that to
talk about it you have to look at it
first
rather than dreaming about it I think
mark just let me finish I'm not dreaming
here I just began what I said admitting
that we are in a difficult situation
that is not the language of a dreamer
that's the language of someone trying to
talk sensibly like you to an audience
what do you propose I can't see any
other political solution that makes
sense then if we talk democracy to live
by democracy give people the chance for
the first time in their history to
choose a transitional administration put
together the machinery for an election
in January get to find
elections in the end of 2005 will people
try to sabotage it of course they will
will people be killed trying to vote of
course they will will people be
intimidated of course they were they
will as the Madrid and Spanish
electorates were intimidated in March if
you want democracy sometimes you have oh
you how you sound when you do that
ladies and gentlemen you can always tell
whether morons are sitting when they s
in the interest of a certain restrain
yourselves and allow the panelists to
finish I'm a look I'm a let's just clear
up the Spanish matter all right this the
Spanish people know more about terrorism
than any other liberal democracy right
they're entirely entitled to vote as
they wish to vote if they wish as Bob
characterized them to vote against the
government that drag them into the war
in Iraq absolutely they're right god
bless them fine but let's be serious
here there was a very serious bombing
two days before an election and anybody
who doesn't think that that's a
deliberate attempt by terrorists to
influence and tip the scales of a
democratic election just isn't being
serious and if you think that isn't
going to happen here you haven't seen
anything yet that's where we're going
and that's why if you're going to
believe in democracy we're gonna have to
be very tough mark keeps telling me it's
difficult of course it's difficult of
course it's difficult what does he
propose we draw down we get out Oh fine
fine
and leave and leave a people and leave a
people to whom this country made a
solemn promise twenty six million people
we made a promise to 26 million people
and let me tell you something else we
made a promise to over six hundred
people who've just shed their lives on
behalf of this so if we're going to get
out there's an element of betrayal and
we ought to be clear about that I don't
try I'm not dreaming any dreams I'm
trying to deal really
with the hopes and expectations and
opportunities that twenty-six million
people have to live a decent life there
they're not going to live the way you
and either the democracy they're going
to get isn't going to look like
the founding fathers democracy but it
might be the first real democracy in
this region I think it's worth the
effort and of course it's going to be
difficult I'm just simply saying the
thing about the other side of the house
is they bear no
burden of responsibility for telling us
what we do now how do we fix the
situation which I fully can see which I
fully can see is just about as difficult
as they portray but the problem is irony
here irony we're too late for irony
ladies and gentlemen we have to be
practical we have to be resolute we have
to be firm and above all we have to show
a little basic courage of which this
country always has plenty Thank You mr.
Johnson and now to Robert Scheer you
know I've been up against this argument
all my life I was in Vietnam in 64 65 we
had sent flood control advisors I said
leave this country alone leave Cambodia
alone somehow I became responsible for
58 59 thousand Americans dying and
according to Robert McNamara 3.4 million
indo-chinese people the analogy with
that war as we were told those people
could not manage their own affairs they
could not make their own history and if
we left it would be this horror for them
and for the rest of the world we now
have a situation where boat people are
returning to Vietnam where they're
building their retirement homes the
consequence of art getting out cut and
run was they went to war with China an
event never predicted by our experts
read Vietnam went to war with the Red
China they didn't invade San Diego we
didn't have to fight him there a fight
him here
so the whole web allies were the same
and my own feeling you're not gonna gut
check me with this thing about what we
owe to the dead you know when I had
fired written more effectively if I had
been tougher in 64 65 if the peace
movement had been stronger we wouldn't
lost a 5859 thousand people he went to
lost the millions
so let me just tell you flat out I don't
think leaving is an immoral position we
are part of the problem the longer we
stay there the deeper the problem
becomes we are creating enemy we are
uniting the Shiites and the Sunnis we
are building the fanaticism us this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy this was a
secular society hate said I'm all you
want the fact is he was at war with the
bin Laden's you know and we top of that
now religious fanaticism has full sway
and I would point out we this
administration has totally ignored the
progress that was made on the
palestinian-israeli peace process not a
word about it you know and then to turn
around and give Cheryl a blank check so
instead of this war calming the area we
now have Jordan in Egypt at our throats
Jordan will not meet with our president
the game Jordan and we have with the
worst situation of Theo's
neoconservatives of friends of Israel
Israel does not need enemies Israel has
never been in a weaker position than now
but if you don't like to get out
position I have a better position for
you and the one you demean does the
carry position you know we should do
what we did in Afghanistan after 9/11 we
had the support of the whole world we
blew it what is wrong with going to the
institution that Eleanor Roosevelt our
government did more to create than
anyone else saying to this institution
to these people you were right we didn't
find those weapons of mass destruction
you were doing a hell of a job okay we
want you back in great nations committed
admit mistakes or they dig deeper into
the hole and we want you to come in not
as a fig leaf not to cover as you were
going to do with the coalition Iraqi
government who's going to take that
seriously you can't control your own arm
you can't control the Americans but
you're paving the way for democracy I
see nothing unrealistic that are not
pragmatic about going to the United
Nations and saying we want you to run
this operation now we have already been
told by the Spanish government by the
French by the Germans by the Chileans by
plenty of people that we respect in this
world that were that demand ate they
would do what they're doing in
Afghanistan they would do what they're
doing in the water
war on terror can only be fought with
the cooperation of all of these
governments and their Police
Department's they didn't cut and run on
Afghanistan they didn't cut and run on
terror
they cut if that's the word you want to
use against our folly they know what the
price of colonialism is you're going to
lecture the Spanish the French and
German or what happens when you get into
these Follies they know about cafes
being burned up up so what I'm saying is
that the position you demean the Kerry
position is the one people should
support in this election my only
criticism Micheli
is I wanted to wage it more vigorously I
want Kerry to give the speech that he
gave in Congress when he said who's the
last man that died for a mistake you're
telling me you want to send more young
Americans to die for a mistake so if
that what we need to do is get the new
Kerry to be the old Kerry you know
because what that guy what Kerry did was
he said ok I'll fight for my country
you know I'll buy your lie and hope it's
wrong I'll go there I believe in
patriotism I believe in loyalty he
leaves after five months of wounds in
combat and everything else that he says
I'm not going to go off into the private
sector I'm not going to shut up
I'm gonna form Vietnam Veterans Against
the War I'm gonna debate a bit and I'm
gonna bring my comrades my buddies back
home
it was the most honorable thing to do it
on its face a lone reason to make this
guy president instead of a guy who got
us into a dangerous war where people
attend
we're gonna use our remaining time to
ask a number of questions to try to
think seriously about that enduring
question what is to be done whether the
United States was right to intervene
whether it did so on a pretext which it
knew disingenuously to be false or
whether it did so for moral purposes a
high-minded purposes the fact is there
135,000 troops in Iraq today the country
is at war whether or not the exit
strategies that have been proposed some
of which have been discarded whether or
not there is a mechanism in place that
seems sensible what is to be done now is
a very it seems to be very crucial if
let's just ask a question Christopher I
put it to you even accepting say your
argument which I take it rests more on a
kind on the blood debt as it were that
the United States owes to the
long-suffering Iraqi people to rid
themselves of a of a bloody despot who
to be sure the United States helped to
prop up to coddle to aid when it was
convenient for the United States to do
so and in the end let's say for the best
of motives recognizing the error of its
historical ways now having written
presented by a history they consciously
forged to undo the different terrible
work that they had they had done so so
much to advance intervened topple
Hussein from power let us say that the
standard bearers of of that liberation
let us take them at their word to say
that they are Tribune's
of democracy and a model that the Iraqi
people in the widest number can enjoy
isn't there a problem here in trying to
make another people's history for them
isn't there the great risk that the
hubris required to do that will engender
a reaction not one of relief but one as
time goes on in which the occupied even
occupiers they may initially have
welcomed turn out to be those they feel
they would like to be rid of isn't there
a fundamental problem in not
leading people to make their own history
and doesn't that compromise the very
effort the United States insists its
embarked upon very well you're even
getting applause for a question that's
good that's splendid in fact let's see
the time to protest would have been 1998
I think when the Senate adopted the Iraq
liberation act without a dissenting
voice when it agreed and declared very
Roth had become our responsibility and
that the cynic trend known of future
progress was the removal of the Saddam
Hussein regime that would have been the
time to say you're dragging us into a
war with this you don't have an exit
strategy yet this looks like an entrance
strategy to us that would have been the
time to complain and nobody did because
it was self-evident that one could not
go on anymore
in coexistence with the Saddam Hussein
regime either for the sake of the Iraqi
people or our own we didn't want either
a failed state or a rogue state or the
combination of the two those problems
would not have been Vietnamese as I told
you before they would have been Rwandan
Somalian q squared and that's what we've
avoided by the way and that really would
have been a quagmire let's look then at
the question of taking over Iraq history
for it for the case of the only part of
Iraq that's been free of Saddam Hussein
for longer than a year
Michael's already mentioned it this is a
release of the latent energies of the
Kurdish people there are 21 newspapers
in Erbil there are three female High
Court judges there are enormous numbers
of political reform I think there are
four maybe it's 300 now American
soldiers in those provinces of Iraq I
think they're mainly there for
decoration and the the Kurds if they
wanted to have a national day would
probably pick the fourth of July and
indeed recently they said to those who
were there don't worry you can get
Fallujah if you feel you need extra
troops we don't need you here that's the
direct result of a regime change policy
it's something we could and should be
very proud of having done we've assisted
the largest people in the region who
don't have a state the Kurds to begin to
acquire self-government they're many
more of them than there are Palestinians
they'd be far worse treated there no one
has ever been hit
Kurdish suicide bomber and no one ever
will be this is a noble cause we do
right to be on their side we want to
repeat this in the rest of Iraq it's
going to be tough because we wasted 10
years 10 years went to the locust in
this matter but since the entry of the
coalition first Kurdish autonomy second
refloating the areas of the the marshes
the largest wetlands in the Middle East
that had been dried out burned and
destroyed by Saddam Hussein UNESCO his
greatest top 10 of top of the top 10 of
international crimes against ecology the
smoke from that destruction could be
seen from the space shuttle the Arabs of
the marshes are returning to their
ancient ecology that areas being
refloated up to a million we're not sure
exactly up to a million Iraqis have come
home there were four and a half million
exhales until last year people were
unable to live in their own country
about a million of them have come back
these tend to be professional types with
qualifications to be living in exile in
democratic societies they have a right
of return as well and of course the
effort is being made by the jihadists
and the fascists not to give this a
chance to breathe not to let it develop
a pulse because they know they will lose
but the good bit is this the US Armed
Forces is are acquiring daily we are
acquiring an army that has bitter hard
experience in nation-building and
countering jihad don't think ladies and
gentlemen you're not going to be needing
this force again it's going to be needed
more and more as the wall of jihad goes
on and deepens and intensifies so we're
going to get much better at finding and
eradicating without pity these people
are much better at working on projects
like the marshes like the empowerment of
women like the building of an electoral
register yes it's incredibly worthwhile
I'd like to who should be proud we
should be proud of having done it and
some states are getting the point did
when Curl Gaddafi wanted to capitulate
he said okay I'll give up my weapons
they're no use to me or anyone else
they're there they're a threat there are
nuisance it was a huge mistake I'll show
you where they are I'll give them up and
furthermore I'll join you in the war
against bin Laden did you go to Kofi
Annan to make this offer
no did he go to jacques chirac to make
this often no he didn't did he go to
Chancellor schröder - no he did not he
came to mr. Blair and mr. Bush you said
okay that's it I'm taking regime changes
of is a fact in the region and a
necessity for Iraq I'd like to ask a
question of Michael Ignatieff Michael
you give very eloquent a voice to your
or your being troubled in the aftermath
of the reasons first advanced for going
to war in Iraq
you seem also to insist that a return to
involvement of the of the United Nations
on even a more vigorous level than
perhaps is the case today continues to
trouble you and yet the administration
itself has turned to the United Nations
in a kind of de facto confession that it
does in fact need the multilateralism of
a world that it's more unilateral
impulses had so vigorously spurned and
isn't it a more prudent and sensible a
course for the United States to involve
itself in a more invigorated United
Nations rather than trying to keep it at
arm's length and so in feeling the very
institution that even the spin Meister's
might concede would be the very fig leaf
and conceit that the administration's of
desperately deeds at this moment look
I'm a pretty unequivocal began possibly
in distinction from Chris and also in
distinction from others I'm I'm a pretty
strong believer in the United Nations on
under certain circumstances there are a
few people whose political sagacity and
wisdom I admire more than Lakhdar
Brahimi because I've been in Afghanistan
and I see see what this very this wily
old Fox from Algeria was able to
accomplish in terms of creating a
political process in Afghanistan and I'm
hoping and praying as I think we all
should be that this wily old Fox can do
it in Iraq and I don't believe I don't
believe that this is impossible but
that's essentially the key part of a
multilateral commitment that is to get
the political process out from under the
Coalition Provisional Authority and into
the hands of an international broker who
has international legitimacy I don't
think I think the Bob Scheer may have
misunderstood my point about Kerry
I just don't think give it to the United
Nations is actually a policy I'm not
opposed to that but I think even Bob was
saying he wants a stronger clearer more
articulate policy that makes sense and I
feel the same way it's I'm not opposed
to multilateral involvement by the UN I
just think we've got some of it now and
it seems to me a fantasy to put this
under a kind of UN trusteeship because
of capacity problems I just think if you
go up to the 28th floor of the UN as I
occasionally do and you ask them could
you run Iraq they say unfortunately we
cannot so it's not an objection in
principle to multilateral action it's
you know since mark wants me to avoid
dreaming I do want to avoid dreaming and
there may be an element of wishing the
UN to take this over that involves
dreaming the United States will have to
stay centrally engaged it should get
other people in to contribute it should
get other countries to contribute to
reconstruction to development but the
political process has to be held by
Lakhdar Brahimi we need to support that
but the expectation that the UN can sort
of take this burden off the United
States electorate and just kick it into
the long grass seems to me to be
precisely what Mark doesn't want me to
do namely dreaming
mark asks for a response to that I'm
gonna give him a response but I'd like
to put a question to you as well why
don't you respond for a minute or so and
then I'll ask you a question well I just
want to say you know there's always a
point that we reach in these debates
where the people who argued strongly for
war say to the ones who objected that
don't fixate on the past tell us what to
do now don't fixate on the past night
when this happened in New York I
essentially said I feel like a guy
walking down the street see someone
coming toward him this person approaches
and then punches punches him in the face
you're lying on the ground and you look
up at this person and say why did you
hit me in the face and that person says
don't fixate on the past you know I
agree I agree with Michael I mean I
think Kerry's policy just to hand it
over to the UN the moment for that has
passed unfortunately there isn't a UN
there are no UN forces you need to get
countries willing to supply troops to
come in and do it I agree with Michael
on that point I also I disagree with Bob
I don't think the US can can withdraw
precipitously from Iraq unfortunately I
think we're caught there we're adding
troops now not taking them out the
Pentagon at this point wanted to have
30,000 Americans there 135,000 now and
there will be more so I don't think
there's an easy way out I think the the
political side of this has to be
internationalized it has to be given
over to the United Nations the US has to
open up reconstruction contracts and
everything else to other countries it
has to be willing essentially to climb
down from the position it took before
the war of complete control of this
occupation and of thumbing its nose at
the international community but I agree
with Michael it's going to be difficult
difficult difficult regardless in the
notion that there's a clear way out here
in a clear solution there might have
been before the war if we'd had more
troops there the original plan for the
United States to have a two-year
occupation and a steady building of
political parties over a period of years
and enough occupation troops that might
have worked better but at the moment
I don't see a clear a clear solution for
this and the UN is not the UN has to be
a part of it but it's not going to get
the United States out of out of Iraq
state is is what you've painted here
really a serious position though in the
sense that you virtually concede that
the United States has the own has has
the resources and power on the ground in
order to shape whatever immediate future
will will occur in Iraq what is it that
you actually mean when you say
internationalization what is it that you
actually mean when you say involve the
United Nations more heavily how would
that qualitatively and by what means
reshape the present predicament I think
the United Stated nations have has to be
given over has to be given control of
the political changeover in Iraq I think
the United States has to essentially
appeal to the international community in
a way it hasn't done before it has to
try to get NATO forces into Iraq it has
to try to persuade its allies to help it
in some of the things that those forces
can do in Iraq but the fact is that the
French the Germans I mean as bob has
pointed out there are very large
majorities in those countries that don't
want to do that and so it is going to be
difficult I mean I think that you know
one of the lessons here is that it is
very hard to make people Democrats by
shooting them it's very hard you know
I've covered Haiti I've covered Bosnia I
mean Michael has been over the same
ground so if the others up here I mean
it's it's very difficult to do this and
you have to look at the country and say
well what's there what are we starting
with and in Iraq you have an artificial
state that's been ruled by a minority
that has a majority that's desperate to
take power but who's taking of power is
viewed by the US policymakers as
threatening I mean one of the problems
now with handing over power is the u.s.
major policymakers here don't want
radical Shiites to take power in
Arak and as the occupation continues the
chance of that eventually happening
grows ever greater and that's the
paradox that were confronted with I
don't want to be negative I mean I take
Michaels criticisms very much to heart
I'd like to stand up and give you a very
clear op-ed page you know this is what
we should do we have a kanita confederal
solution we need the UN on the political
side we should get out on such-and-such
a date but the fact is that these
alternatives one by one have gone by the
wayside we haven't had enough troops to
occupy the country and make make it
secure Shinseki before the war said we
need several hundred thousand he didn't
pick that number out of the air he
that's what the army had determined you
needed to secure the country well we
decided to do it with half that we
decided to dream our dreams about how
easy this would be and the fact is that
we can't go back over those grounds I
agree with Michael that I think this is
going to be very difficult I think a lot
more Americans are going to die I think
a lot lot more Iraqis are going to die
but I can't see a rationale that would
envision just America pulling out and
not leaving a complete civil war so I'm
stuck in the position that someone wrote
me an angry email saying called me a
liberal supporter of the occupation
because I don't advocate pulling out
precipitously but having opposed the war
and having argued again and again that
the occupation would be bloody difficult
Steve I don't see a way to get out
instantly it just doesn't seem to me to
be it seems to me to be that would be
the cause of much greater bloodshed than
there is now thank you Mark
let me let me speak let me ask about a
Bob Scheer a question mr. Schue you've
made a very distinguished career
pointing out human rights abuses in many
places over many decades and yet in some
of your remarks while you have a kind of
parenthetical acknowledgment of the been
vampiric qualities of the now deposed
dictator Saddam Hussein and you are
quite
vociferous when you point out the ways
in which past administrations had
coddled him it seems to occupy a lesser
place in your political how to put your
political cartography than the
disingenuous hypocrisy z' of the
american administration and so one has
rather the feeling that what your
empathy for the iraqi people is somehow
not as robust as your unhappiness at at
the paradoxes and predicaments of
various American administrations as they
pursue policies that you regard as
inconsistent yet what are we to do we
are now in the debate over the weapons
of mass destruction while a continuing
importance for the civic education of
the polity seems to have no genuine
relevance in the construction of a
policy that would actually take take
seriously what we are to do in the Iraq
that we are now presented with in which
we and which we now occupy what is your
position well I guess your assertion is
I'm insensitive to Iraqi lives because I
don't want to bomb them and shoot him
and invade their cities I think there is
something wrong about saying the death
of four Americans I gather they were
mercenaries highly paid who are in a
country I don't know what who sent them
there we didn't vote to send them there
that that can justify destroying a city
that seems to be the issue at Fallujah
clearly if these if we came to Iraq to
free these people we must believe they
have the capacity to rule themselves
Saddam Hussein maybe no one has noticed
is in jail you know their military was
broken so and we have now admitted
finally we have to include the Baathists
they're not all evil they weren't all
terrible people so my argument would be
why not trust the Iraqis to make their
own history I don't see how that becomes
an anti Human Rights position on the
contrary I think we have cheapened the
coinage of human rights
I think that there is first of all we
should intervene wherever it genocide
seems to be in the offing I'm in favor
of it I was in favor of the invasion of
Afghanistan did sending the cruise
missiles and because I thought again
these people had attacked our embassies
our ships they clearly were one of the
same bin Laden and and we were able to
do with international support and
understanding so the issue is not going
in to protect human lives the issue is
whether going in cost more in the way of
human lives and it's very easy to say
here oh let's have some so American
soldiers I'm thinking of the ones that
I've met and I'm not taking anything
away from them that they're two years or
a year three years out of high school
they could hardly find Iraq on the map
they know nothing about this history
they've been lied to by their president
that this has something to do with
protecting our country that's why the
lies are important because it's those
troops that were lied to and I know if
we had a draft let me assure you the
American public would not be at all as
passive as it has been on this issue you
go ask those neighbors of yours
60% of Californians in the LA Times poll
said they don't think this is worth the
cost of American lives two to one in the
state thank you Mr Shearer we will now
have closing remarks from each of the
panelists Christopher Hitchens oh gee I
wasn't ready um well these are events
taking place along which these
perspiration I know I should have
realized I was on television how long
are these closing remarks five minutes
okay
I'll probably be able to yield some of
that time back to the other the other
comrades I think I'll have to say I have
to say something about Vietnam in
closing the United States policies was
the Vietnam was based upon an arbitrary
partition of Vietnam there was imposed
in 1954 based on upholding that
artificial partition this is the first
of the major differences though if the
US was the sort of country people
sometimes seem to think it is it could
let Iraq
fragment and balkanized and probably do
just as well in getting oil out of it
that way the attempt is being made to
keep a federal democracy together that's
another difference the Vietnamese
government even at its most Stalinist
was never accused of genocide nor did it
invade neighboring countries nor is it
the the prime suspect in sponsoring
international terrorism Saddam Hussein
took credit personally and we know from
the bank records that he was made good
on it for every suicide bomber in
Palestine there was a bounty the the
heroes of the World Trade Center of 1994
found refuge in Iraq these are generally
how and how I can multiply anymore the
absurdity of the analogy with Vietnam
and as I said earlier the appalling
insult that it constitutes to our
Vietnamese friends the the analogy I'll
say again is with what might have
happened this is not to dwell on the
past
nor is it to say to people well even if
you opposed the war you're stuck with it
now that's no part of our case is to say
what was your proposal then what was
your proposal faced with a maimed torn
traumatized violent Iraq and with a
crime family in charge of its gigantic
resources and it's enormously swollen
armed forces and with a psychopathic a
couple in the in the dynasty waiting to
seize power how long would you have let
this run now I don't think I've heard
anything like an answer to that question
from either of our two opponents today
they haven't even attempted it they've
every time I asked it they've acted as
if I hadn't brought it up as if the Iraq
Liberation Act had never been passed as
if the serial resolutions of the United
Nations with none of which Iraq would
comply had never been passed mr. Brahimi
of the UN is a friend of mine I used to
know him when he was Algerian ambassador
to London he was quite a good envoi in
Afghanistan but his job was hopeless
nothing happened in Afghanistan until
and NATO forces enter the country and
forcibly removed the Taliban
that's the sheer fact of the matter
there was nothing the UN could do or had
ever done about Afghanistan that
compared to that act of determined
unilateralism if you wish mr. Brahimi is
a member of the Algerian FLN his
government and party and armed forces
had to fight a war against Islamic
fascism in Algeria
over the past decade that's the real
Battle of Algiers by the way ladies and
gentlemen in which probably a hundred
two hundred fifty thousand of people
were killed the large majority of them
I'm happy to say supporters of the jihad
that's what it took Algeria to win the
civil war that's going on in the Islamic
world are we spectators to this are we
as the word elective I think was used an
optional war are we really saying we are
neutral in this civil war in this night
world we'll wait we'll wait and see how
it comes out it's none of our business
let's let it run let's not get involved
because it sure is a quagmire to have a
civil war in the Islamic world it's a
terrible thing but it's not our choice
it's been forced upon us the decision
has been made by the enemies of
civilization to try and win this war by
bringing it to us it is in my opinion
therefore a most excellent use of the
United States Armed Forces which are
very large indeed very well financed and
very well paid for and trained very
numerous and all volunteers no better
use for them could be found than to
involve them in the remaking of a
society that is being and has been
devastated by our enemies in the civil
war not just to make sure that those
enemies are ruthlessly defeated and both
mr. shear and mr. Jinnah were appalling
ly flippant about this they said you
can't change people's minds by shooting
them in effect we don't want to have to
shoot or bomb anybody in what world are
they living you don't make people
Democrats by shooting them but you can
defend and and protect the people who
are Democrats by shooting those by
killing those who are determined to this
democracy there's no better cure for
fascism has ever been found than lead
poisoning on that scale and I think we
should be extremely proud of young
American and British and men and women
of other nationalities too who have
taken on this task on our behalf we have
to wish them very well and it would be a
fool they would had a wicked fool who
thought that if this enterprise fails
and it may we are all alive to the
possibilities of defeat that if this
enterprise fails it will be defeat for
President Bush it takes a wicked fool to
think that takes a wicked fool to think
that a gloating fool of the sort who
have heard a little of the from today to
say that this would be that this would
be only a defeat for Bush it would be a
defeat for civilization and for society
entirely and we have made that we have
no choice but to regard in that light
well because thank you thank you very
much Christopher Hitchens ladies and
gentlemen among you thank you please
please hold your applause and other
remarks mark dinner
well we're hearing again and again that
this was a war that had to be fought
there was no choice the regime was
imploding there would have been a Rwanda
coming in Iraq more and more exotic
claims are proliferating but you have a
great advantage all of you in the
audience and all of you watching which
is that you were there you watched what
happened in the months before the war
you watched the slow effort of
persuasion of the administration you
watched the vote in Congress you watch
the claims about weapons of mass
destruction you watched the claims about
uranium from Africa aluminum tubes all
the rest of it and you know that this
was a war of choice and not of necessity
Saddam Saddam by the beginning of this
war was as Bob putted a defang dictator
his armed forces were a third or a
quarter of the size they were when the
Gulf War was fought in 91 he had a bunch
of twenty-year-old rusting tanks he had
no weapons of mass destruction as we've
discovered he did not pose a threat to
the United States he did not pose a
threat to the region he was a bloody
tyrant but the notion that the United
States had to invade a year thirteen
months ago is ridiculous and all of you
know that it's not true by the way the
1998 Iraq liberation Act does not
require a Wars you may have noticed the
Clinton administration did not invade
Iraq and it's a bit of sophistry to say
that again and again as if the United
States had committed to war in 1998 you
know sometimes things are as simple as
they appear and if you look at this I
think just squarely through the
newspapers through the news you realize
a couple of things one is that the war
came first the rationale for it later
this was a war that the United States
government the bush administration
wanted to fight and then it went off in
search of reasons Michael has denounced
the use of trumped-up evidence to
support the war he says he won't sign on
for that but at the same time he admits
that without
that trumped-up evidence the American
people could not have been brought along
as he put it to support the war that's a
contradiction for someone who believes
in democracy the question is if you
believe a war government cannot convince
its people to go to war is the
government legitimate in lying to the
people and is it legitimate to lying to
the international community
christopher's assertions about this war
had to be fought to change minds well we
have evidence about the changing of
minds that have happened since this war
was fought and the evidence that we have
the polling from the Middle East from
the Islamic world shows that the the
opinion of the United States of the
United States troops of the United
States government has fallen
catastrophic ly since this war was
fought and those numbers continue to go
down so if indeed this was a war to
promote democracy throughout the Islamic
world if this was a war to change minds
change the balance of powers if that's
if that was our purpose in Iraq changed
them what we know what we know thus far
is that the minds are changing in the
opposite direction balance of power my
my problem with this war in the end is
that I believe it has made us less safe
I believe at a time when the American
armed forces were needed to fight in
other venues were needed in Afghanistan
were needed to protect this country when
the 200 billion dollars that has already
been spent in Iraq was needed to secure
the ports harbors nuclear plants
chemical plants of this country instead
that money those resources and worst of
all those young American lives have been
wasted in a war that didn't need to be
fought everybody
it's natural for you to want hope
it's natural for you to reject a
relentlessly negative view of what's
going on and I would try to give you
some hope my hope would be that the
American people would have learned from
the events of the last 13 my hope would
be that Americans would take a more
skeptical view of what their government
says and what it does my hope would be
that instead of listening to our leaders
and taking what they say on faith we
read the paper and look at the events in
front of us and make our own decision my
hope would be that in the fall decisions
would be made that would lead to a
different attitude in Iraq and a
different attitude in fighting the war
on terror that is the most positive I'm
afraid most positive view I can give you
about Iraq because the way in Iraq from
now on is going to be bloody frustrating
and difficult and Michael said difficult
I agree with him it's going to be
difficult and we can talk about the
United Nations we can talk about handing
over political control we can talk about
bringing other countries in countries
that up to now we've spurned but all of
this is going to be increasingly hard
because none of them want to get
involved in a war that's going
increasingly badly I hope we monitor for
next time
closing remarks from closing remarks
from Michael like nacho I want to start
with wars of choice versus wars of
necessity I think everybody feels
naturally that you don't want to fight
wars of choice you want to restrain the
use of military force you want to use it
as a last resort when I my first remarks
to you tonight I said that I could
justify pre-emptive war but only is the
last resort so but let's focus on one
painful and unpleasant reality about war
which is this country has been at war
for 20 years from the bombing of the
American Embassy in Beirut in 1983
through a rising escalation of terror
attacks which we didn't connect as a
sustained combat operation and only woke
up on 9/11 connecting the dots back over
a 20-year rising escalation of attacks
on American targets they have been at
war for with us for 20 years it seems to
me at a certain point it would be
appropriate to be at war with them this
war was not in my judgment a war of our
choosing a kind of needless wandering
around the world in search of people to
beat up this war was started in 1983 by
people we didn't even recognize as our
enemies and now only to pound puppy
grasp that we are in a war I'm not sure
I characterize it exactly as Christopher
Hitchens does but I certainly know what
side I'm on do I want them to win you
must be joking
why because I love this country I love
its institutions I have a passionate
commitment to liberal democracy as
everybody on the other side of the panel
does and when it's attacked I think we
ought to defend it so let's work beyond
the wars of choice wars of necessity
dichotomy and understand that war was
declared against us in others it then
there's a question then there
a question of how that war is fought and
there's a entirely legitimate
disagreement about how we prosecute it
my sense of it is this simple I'll leave
you with one simple thought the national
security of the United States that is to
say the survival and health of liberal
democracy as we know it in this country
is integrally related to the security of
three other places first of all it's
related our security is related to the
security of the State of Israel a secure
Israel within stable 1967 borders is in
the national interest of the United
States self-evidently in the national
interest of the Jewish people secondly
let me finish third the third country
where we in which our national security
is deeply tied is in the rights of the
Palestinian people to have a contiguous
viable State on the West Bank and Gaza
in other words the security of the
United States the security of Israel and
the security the Palestinians are locked
together one of the things that Bush has
got wrong and here I entirely agree with
Bob Scheer is green-lighting settlements
on the West Bank is a problem because it
makes the Palestinian state non-viable
if you don't have a Palestinian state
you have a hundred war Years War Indian
in the Middle East a hundred years war
which Israel cannot win and the United
States cannot win so we have to have the
national security of the United States
the national security of Israel the
national security of Palestine linked
together and forth and finally and this
is where Iraq comes in you can't have
all of those three linked together
unless you have a stable secure
democratic federal Iraq
we're linked these four elements have to
come together the Bush administration
hasn't got it the Kerry campaign and my
judgment hasn't got it but we had better
get it because our security and then
safety of this Republic depends on us
understanding the relation national
security the United States national
security of Israel national security of
Palestine and a free and democratic Iraq
it's all difficult ladies and gentlemen
everything worth doing is difficult but
we at least need to know what the target
is and that believe me is the target and
it's what I'm prepared to support
Robert Scheer yeah I just want to say
it's been a great session for me because
all my life I was intimidated by the
notion of people who went to Harvard or
Oxford or Cambridge might have some
wisdom I only bring this up in this now
went to City College in New York and we
learned how to you know the whole lot of
never [ __ ] a bullshitter you know I
wanna bring my excuse me bringing this
up in a personal way no excuse me it is
well language over Riley of language
over Riley and Limbaugh and others not
used to denigrate those of us who dare
differ as wicked fools gloating fools I
am deeply offended at the idea that I
that I am gloating over the loss of
young Americans and Iraqis of all ages
I find that distasteful I went back to
Vietnam seven years ago to report from
Microsoft I went to Cambodia I know what
it looks like to have people and have
limbs on I saw all the graves
I saw what we did to a country of
Cambodia that did not need change and
which two million people died I've had
Ron Kovic come in my class with half of
his body because he followed the John
Wayne image and went to Vietnam and was
so severely wounded I resent the idea
that people who favor peace gloat over
American casualties gloat over death how
dare you how dare you suggest that
how dare you suggest that those of us
who opposed this war and a president who
said he was not interested in us to
materialize your actions they said it
was not interested in nation-building if
you're gonna lie to the wagon that you
have let materialized aside to the
American public at every single point we
tried to stop this carnage before it
happened we tried to say this was unwise
you're the ones that told us it was
absolutely necessary you're the ones
that told us there was this imminent
threat to our security that there were
these weapons semester which by the way
David K now says we there is no you
don't even mention that you're the ones
that told us this war was absolutely
essential to un had to be bypassed and
now you dare say that those of us who
want to bring it into it as quickly as
possible and I said yes use the UN as
vigorously as possible but don't let
this drag on for 10 15 more years if you
saw the movie fog of war where McNamara
cries you'll learn about how Quagmire's
have made the argument is were in we
can't just leave-- nonsense
you can just leave you're gonna make it
worse worse you know so don't try to
seize the the moral high ground and let
me tell you something else you know
there were plenty of us who said this
whole idea terror is international first
of all you know enough about the Mideast
to know that the Islamic fundamentalist
terrorists and the secular dictators
have not been on the same side you know
that you know that 1983 change was our
secular Ally because he was taking on
the Shiites of Iran that's why we backed
them
that's why Rumsfeld shook hands with him
that year you know that Sadat was killed
by a member of the dresden brotherhood
so to say now which side are you on
which side are you on is to blur what
the 9/11 Commission by the way is
looking into which this president has
never been interested in what was the
role of Pakistan what did the Saudis do
why were there 15 of 19 hijackers from
Saudi Arabia
why was Saudis allowed to leave the
country who needed to be interrogated
why
I wrote a column which I've been blasted
on the internet I wrote it in May before
September 11th I wrote it in the LA
Times and I said why are we putting 43
million dollars in a and congratulating
the Taliban for controlling the opium
crop and that you know demanding that
they you know not going in there and
getting rid of the bin Laden's already
attacked us and then in August before
September 11th and we haven't talked at
all about these revelations of the
September 11th commission you want you
want to make it suggest that we don't
care about terror
you're ignoring this investigation and
what they have found out is this
administration didn't care and in fact
in August before 9/11 four or five weeks
before christina Roca from our State
Department meant with the Taliban and
Bacchus Bassett er in Pakistan and
congratulated once again on controlling
the opium problem and we know that condi
rice his speech prepared for September
11th was on this idiocy of Star Wars
protection and wasn't going to mention
terrorism so we have an ample record
here of a difference to terrorism we
know that our intervention in the past's
overthrowing master day in Iran which
produced eventually the Ayatollah
bringing santim Hussein as someone who
could assassinate custom he was one of
our guys Adam Hussein then you turn
around after we try to work when it was
an ally for 10 years and you're gonna
blame the two of us here somehow
for not being vigorous enough and
getting rid of them the guy has been
gotten rid of the country we were going
to liberate is liberated why don't we
let those people vote why are we against
elections that's the big issue here if
we clear interest in democracy why will
we not trust the Iraqi people to control
their own concession we shall
just
late ladies and gentlemen there is no
doubt but that the Gordian knot that is
presented to us by the mess in
Mesopotamia involves more issues and
mork unresolved questions than alas we
have time for but what is certain is
that the greatest number of people with
opinions who really matter are you in
the audience and you watching this
program for it is your active
participation in this debate which
should treat all of these issues and as
yet
that is an important that it is
important for you to attend to as the
days unfold and as the next year goes by
thank you very much for your attention